[Musique]
on pourrait appeler ça la bulle du
bonheur dans les aéroports de nouvelle
zélande et d'australie ces derniers
jours il y à des scènes de joie qui ne
trompent pas certains rentrent chez eux
d'autres retrouvent compagne famille ou
amis après de longs mois de séparation
je vais crier hurler pleurer et rendre
embrasser être heureuse de toutes ces
émotions en même temps j'en suis sûr se
rendre de l'autre côté de la mer de
tasman sans passer par la case
quarantaine c'est désormais possible
plus d'un an après la fermeture totale
des frontières néo zélandaise et
l'isolément forcé des deux voisins
je suis tout aussi excité que denise et
c'est génial de voyager ensemble
je suis bien sûr car je suis une grande
tente et une tante qui va voir sa nièce
et neveu et ses petits neveux et nièces
nous vivons en australie depuis 33 ans
mais ma meilleure amie est en nouvelle
zélande
si ces deux expatriés kiwi peuvent enfin
retrouver leurs proches et leurs maisons
c'est que les mesures restrictives sont
une réussite dans leur pays de 1600 cas
confirmés pour la nouvelle zélande et
seulement 26 décès 10 fois plus de
personnes infectées en australie mais
une épidémie contenu moins de 1000 morts
pour 25 millions d'habitants dès octobre
canberra a assoupli ses restrictions
mais willington n'a pas suivi c'est
désormais chose faite
on avait prévu de rentrer en février
cela tournait un peu au cauchemar la
réservation des vols puis la quarantaine
mais bon on est dans une bonne partie du
monde non comment expliquer cette
gestion quasi parfaite
celle là même qui a fait de la nouvelle
zélande et de l'australie
les leaders de la lutte contre le coc
vide l'absence de frontière terrestre et
une densité de population plus faible
qu'en europe l'expliquent en partie des
facteurs bien spécifiques à ces deux
territoires et qu'ils ont dans un
premier temps empêché les contaminations
venant de l'étranger australiens et néo
zélandais récoltent ensuite les fruits
d'une stratégie zéro qu'ovide payante
calquée sur celle de certains pays
asiatiques
mesures strictes dès la découverte d'une
personne infectée confinement et
contrôle drastique des foyers de
contamination
la sensation de voyager entre
l'australie et la nouvelle zélande est
merveilleuse vous savez nous avons
tellement de chance là où nous vivons
c'est tellement merveilleux de pouvoir
aller et venir donc travaillons dur et
gardons nos frontières sûres en
nouvelle-zélande avec la réouverture de
ce pont aérien un secteur reprend vie le
tourisme
queenstown destination prisée avant la
pandémie était devenue une ville fantôme
ici les touristes australiens
représentent 60% des visiteurs étrangers
faute de pouvoir les accueillir la
capitale des sensations fortes a vu sa
fréquentation chuter jusqu'à moins 70%
depuis un an au cours des douze derniers
mois nous n'avons pas dépassé 15 % de
nos chiffres habituels de la période pré
qu'ovide le marché australien en
particulier représentent 50 % de notre
clientèle typique
nous sommes donc impatients de les
retrouver le taux de chômage a atteint
des sommets dans la ville et beaucoup
d'entreprises ont dû mettre la clé sous
la porte avant la saison hivernale qui
démarre fin juin la bulle touristique
est une aubaine pour relancer la machine
à vos marques
le marché des voyages entre la
nouvelle-zélande et l'australie est un
marché un volume très important et il
fonctionne très bien pour les gens des
deux côtés de la mer de tasman c'est une
issue gagnant gagnant que les voyages
trans tasmanien soit rouvert
l'australie comme la nouvelle zélande ne
sont pas débarrassés du coc vie 19 pour
autant un jour après l'ouverture de
cette bulle du bonheur un employé de
l'aéroport d'auckland a été testé
positif au virus
une mise en garde un risque assumé qui
ne remet pas encore en cause les
liaisons restaurée entre les deux pays